so if you're writing a villain character
where do you go because we all have you
know still cliche the dark and a light
right so where do you go there there I
found two ways to write villain
characters in mind you well I've noticed
an interesting thing about my own
writing and this is something I'm just
sort of discovering is that I tend to
not write villains I don't like bad
people
so my villains tend to be external
forces a tornado full of sharks zombies
of an enemy ship hostile aliens things
that you don't really have to get to
know and that's something that I've just
recently been discovering about myself
and thinking that you know I've got to
sort of explore writing more interesting
personal evil characters and how does
one do that obviously one can simply
take all of your anger and
self-justification at things that happen
to you in the world and sort of bundle
them and hang on to them and focus them
into this character and the other way to
do it is to think of the people in your
life who are pissing you off the most
and then imbue your bad guy characters
with some of those traits but at the
same time you have to remember that
everybody even the most evil character
I'm sure even Adolf Hitler thought he
was doing something right and so you
have to be able to establish a logic and
a self justification for any bad guy for
them to have internal credibility and
because if they don't have that they
just become cartoon dick dastardly
characters you know twirling their
moustaches and I'm actually writing one
of those right now and I'm trying one of
my challenges is how do I justify this
character to himself
you